let's get the audience questions for the
week one viewer writing in hey David
given everything that's going on between
Ben Shapiro and Alexandria Acacio Cortez
and Candace Owens and people debating
and the entire Twitter thing would you
debate ben shapiro or candice owens
yeah I would I mean I thought I said I
was involved in this entire Twitter
fiasco over over the weekend connected
to Ben Shapiro and Alexandria Casio
Cortez and Charley Kirk and Candace
Owens and I said I'll debate any of you
nobody has to pay anybody and we'll do
it but the thing about debating is the
following number one I don't know that
they wanted to bait me right I mean at
this point I think Ben Shapiro probably
would not see it as a good use of his
time to come on the show and debate
something number one I just don't think
Candace Owens will do it
i I don't know about you no use of her
time I think I don't know what even what
her platform is like she has a YouTube
channel right
why do you know where she breads a
little black red but she's just like a
fox news contributor and does that sort
of thing too I mean she's also busy I
just don't think that she would want to
do it but the thing about debates is
debate them about what right like the
idea I'm not just going to show up and
debate anyone on any topic so like
affirmative action is one that I think
ben shapiro
is very much against and he talks about
why he's against affirmative action when
he does these college speaking things
that's not one of my main issues so i
wouldn't really be the right person to
debate ben shapiro
about that i would be glad to debate you
know I think Candice Owens challenged
someone I think maybe she challenged
Alexandria acasio Cortez to a socialism
versus capitalism debate that would be
interesting I'm not a socialist right I
am a social democrat and I believe that
most things exist in shades of grey and
I think that highly regulated capitalism
with to foment social good buh-buh-buh
buhbuh but i would still be up for
pushing back against candice Owens
misstatements about both capitalism and
socialism and also Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes is not a socialist in her own
right so I thought she was well I mean
she may identify as a Democratic
Socialist yeah but she seems to be more
of a social democrat Oh see I thought
that's what I thought at first but then
more recently it seemed people were
saying no no no she really is a
Democratic Socialist I guess I'm
confused I guess I
know the answer to that but I'd love to
find out more it seems every time I read
another article it goes back and forth
between saying she says she's a
Democratic Socialist but really she's a
social democrat - oh no no she's really
a Democratic Socialist she does want to
take over of the means of production by
the by society so to speak listen not
the question here but something I am
interested in so yeah listen I would
debate ben shapiro candice Owens I mean
I would really debate anyone if they
want to debate an issue in good faith
assuming that they are relatively
prominent right like every day I get ten
debate invitations from YouTube channels
with a hundred to a thousand subscribers
some people when I say this get mad when
I say there's limited time in the day I
have a a show to produce which is a
full-time job I also am running the
business of the David Pakman show
which is a significant undertaking in
and of itself I can't just accept every
debate with some random youtuber and
people get mad at me but it's just
there's only 24 hours in the day and
some of those hours I've got to be
sleeping but I'm willing to debate
people who who have followings if it's
the right issue and there's a lot of
right issues it's just if you want you
know like once I was invited to debate
brexit with Sargon of Akkad Breck's it's
not my issue you know unlike he has
taken a great interest in American
politics I have an interest in UK
politics in the context of geopolitics
and how it affects the United States but
I'm not like a UK politics expert so I
just wouldn't be the right person to
debate brexit with Sargon yeah it's got
to be the right topic and it has to move
the needle too I mean I think you know
you debating ben shapiro or you debating
candice owens that would actually make
sense because you're all new media
figures Oh fair one of those people
debating Alexandria cause Cortese
doesn't make any sense because it's a
new media figure up to shore the
congressional candidate and I was loved
it I would love it if she did it I don't
think there's anything wrong with it but
you know to get back to the kerfuffle
earlier in the week where the idea it's
crazy she didn't even respond it's like
well she's running for for the House of
Representatives is that is going to LA
to debate ben shapiro
really the thing that at this point she
needs to be doing anyway yes I will
debate